[Music]  vice president joe biden appeared on  meet the press and uh he seemed to  endorse  same-sex marriage take a look  the president has said that his views on  gay marriage on same-sex marriage have  evolved have your views evolved look  i just think  that  the good news is that as more and more  americans be come to understand what  this is all about is a simple  proposition  who do you love  i spent more time with the  soon-to-be president of china vice  president xi i i i wish every american  could see the look of love in my eyes  for him  you know look i've spent a total of  roughly 10 days with him five in china  five here  i've been along with him for  uh for over 30 hours just he and i  publicly and privately and quite frankly  i hope soon we've proposed thank you  there you have it  vice president joe biden is deeply in  love  with chinese vice president xi jinping  it's going to be a fall wedding i'm told  i just worry about jill